I have an unscripted challenge for you
guys you got two hours this is an hour
and a half oh my goodness I could put a
little bit interesting well you don't
have the money no Samuel did give us the
cards three hours maximum three
hundred-pound
okay make this place look amazing run
fast and don't stop the deal
[Music]
[Music]
7% of properties in central London are
listed on Airbnb in bottom comm but most
of them look kind of terrible most of
them look like this like this
I mean honestly how would you feel if
you paid eighty ninety pound for a night
in central London and you came into a
room that was so bland I mean it feels
like I'm in a doctor's waiting room and
this bed is just bare I mean it doesn't
cost that much money to get photos to
get some nice bedding greater thing is
this is the competition so what I'm
thinking is and this is one of the
properties that my company has I'm
thinking we're in central London there
are some issues around 90-day roll and
things like that I've done a whole
nother video about that you can see that
in the description but for this room if
we just spent a few hundred pounds we
could literally make the room so much
better and then the ramps rather than
renting this for like 80 pound a night
you'd get 120 pound annoyed 40 pounds
different the return on investment I'm
just doing a few things in this room
like bed sheets like some pictures like
a mirror the return investment we've got
high so I have none better than the
intelligent speedy incredible interior
design team Amanda and my wife Anne
Amelia what are you guys think of this
room that I like this like with this
actually rent I mean most rooms are even
on spare room most rooms are like this
the competition sucks what do you think
we should do with this with this room of
course of course your background is
interior design and you're just a
creative genius so I have an unscripted
challenge for you guys okay but knowing
seriousness like I want you to make this
room over and I want you to do it fast
how many hours would it take to do this
three hours are you kidding three hours
three hours including like you need a
little cute laundry basket what do you
know you're supposed to get stay from
the time you know isn't I don't even
know this is not my bag
but his how much are you talking to get
it really spiced up and to look
incredible okay here's my challenge my
challenge to you ladies is three hours a
maximum of 300 pound
and I want you to literally make this
place look amazing I want you to push
the rent upon it and I want it to be
booked all year round so three hours
300-pound time starts we've got a
meeting it's hope so you've not got
three hours okay you've got two hours
okay good luck good luck
Ready Set pillows cushion it's like your
definition of push it like a nice throw
I think we should go to Primark
okay you don't have the money no Samuel
could give us the car don't want it to
feel like really crap if you like soft
we'll grab the bat mat and stuff last
week no one would use the hand towels
for it yeah yeah that's how the hand
towel I kinda like this one to be fun
yeah that's quite nice thanks charlie
this is gonna make a difference though
yeah that's really nice it'd be nice if
there was like all sir you know the the
the rectangle ones so if we have two of
these and then like I feel like a black
rectangle does the accent color yes
well this is nice but I think the format
will be good and at the corner an hour
and eight minutes left
hi muck was our best back and it lets
out a little bit so we're gonna have
gonna try the job
I'm surprised to even back but it's not
finished
so everything that lamps so sorry I am
gonna have to stop because we've got a
really important meeting so how long
have you been going to now in 45 minutes
yes yeah we've not had the full three
hours now my short straw okay so I don't
have to I would literally we have to go
so we're gonna have to do have we'd have
to pause the camera you have an hour and
15 minutes to finish later for it's
gonna be dark lair are you free tomorrow
morning yeah okay so tomorrow morning
they're gonna come back they're gonna
finish off I'm not gonna even look oh I
want it to be surprised we're gonna see
if they can do it for three hours I
can't wait to find out how much this bed
will find out what happens tomorrow
morning like 30 years what I found
myself okay so today I will finish in
the room something was giving us half an
hour to finish Connie where so half an
hour
let's go awake with some folk singers
these some cult winners huh tell me
where your people
[Music]
mostly to do a picture yeah that was
quite it was just quite restricted
because of the times and so if we had
like oh we just order stuff it yeah the
only thing we felt like we were missing
was like pictures be honest I mean how
much how much have you spent we spent
204 pounds and okay well under budget if
we had that yeah to be free I think the
thing is the reason I wanted to do this
and the reason for the video is to show
within just a few hours and what tune in
for pounds that's not bad yeah I'm gonna
do this that was 40 pounds yeah yeah 40
pounds you don't need like a wardrobe
awesome yeah it's nice we usually women
[Applause]
no big wardrobe adjust the drawers just
this is really ideal yeah for staying
over for a night so you've got your
stuff you can whack it on if you want to
put it down somewhere but then it's not
like a full-on wardrobe it looks really
really good and also I mean the bed the
bed before was it was everything was
just so bland yeah this is I am now now
let me see what it looks like if I was
to take a picture for the appetizer but
it just looks it just looks nice it
looks nice no I really like it
no the color pops and also the plants it
just brings life to the room yeah
so I'm impressed the only thing that I'm
a bit like mmm about is it just it was a
nice picture yeah which you can you get
a percent cheap Conte yeah yeah was that
just a time thing yes because we have
like the budget we have a year just
under and your price expound yeah yeah
yes definitely more things that we could
add so here's the and here's the thing
and here's the mold for the for the for
the viewers watching this thing is for
just a couple of hundred pounds they
transform a room because obviously this
broom as it was wouldn't have got many
bookings and if he was there ah tried it
they didn't work they didn't work
because your your room looked terrible
they'll take of 204 pounds in a few
hours this would be now fully booked the
amount you'd get would would be more and
it's just that extra cuz I don't wanna I
wouldn't want to come and stay in the
river than I like that didn't look nice
awesome outro time hope you enjoyed the
video if you want to see more videos
like this subscribe drop a comment below
if you want to see me even handed back
on the YouTube channel we'll see you
next time thanks for watching I'm
sitting back and I'm still hoping Lord
gamma I was really open limescale
get into the Batwa chitchat come I had
back in a backtrack my we're gonna stop
increasing it's gotta be original drunk
night subliminal movement but even
though they've never really cried for a
pain main so high star like baby in a
breakaway now let's pursue the children
to the game yeah